So you're told even false prophets, even
[clears throat] false enchanters,
meaning those are not of God, will be
given dreams and visions in which they
will see future events and then the
demons will orchestrate those events to
happen in order to deceive you and
others. This is from God or these are
signs of these gods that exist. Okay,
here's another one.
Matthew 24:23-2
again Jesus now warning people Jesus
warning his disciples by extension us
what are some of the signs that the Lord
will return then if anyone says to you
behold here's the Christ or there he is
do not believe him for false Christs
plural false prophets plural will arise
and will show great signs and wonders so
as to deceive
If possible, even the elect. Behold,
I've told you in advance, their signs
will be so convincing that even
believers will start being shaken in
their faith. Something similar to what
happened to you.
Right? But Jesus said, "I've already
told you it's going to happen." All
right? 2 Thessalonians 2:8-12. The man
of sin, the man of lawlessness,
lawlessness will arise in the latter
days, whom Jesus will then destroy by
the brightness of his appearance and the
breath of his mouth, his lips.
He will be empowered by Satan.
Satan will work through him and energize
him and give him power to do what? And
that lawless one will be revealed whom
the Lord Jesus will slay with the breath
of his mouth and bring to an end by the
appearance of his coming. whose coming
is in accord with the working of Satan.
So, Satan's going to operate in and
through them. And that's in Revelation
13. And Revelation 13 says they'll be
doing miracles
with all power and signs and false
wonders. Notice why are they false
wonders? Because they're wonders aimed
at deceiving you to believe of
falsehood.
But notice, they're going to be doing
signs and wonders with all the deception
of unrighteousness for those who perish.
Now he will deceive you in continuing to
follow your path of unrighteousness
because that's what you want. Who is
going to fall for this lie and buy this
lie? Those who perish. Now why are they
perishing? Because they did not receive
the love of the truth so as to be saved.
So part of their judgment, you don't
want the truth of God. You don't want
the true message and the true God
because no matter how many times God
sends you the true message and convinces
you, your reaction is to oppose,
contradict,
suppress, turn away because you don't
want it. You don't want this message
that tells you to turn away from your
lifestyle. So you want something that
will only
>> solidify you in your way of thinking and
believe. So God says, "All right, then
I'm going to hand you over to the
working of Satan through the Antichrist
to do miracles who will then
solidify your way of life and thinking
because you don't want to change and
believe the truth." For this reason,
what's the reason? Because they don't
love the truth. They don't want the
truth to be saved. For this reason, God
sends upon them a deluding influence.
What does he mean send? Satan cannot
come unless God allows him to come. So
indirectly, God is sending Satan upon
who? Those who don't love the truth. And
as such, God gives them what they want
by allowing Satan to deceive them,
tickling their ears, right? A duning
influence so that they will believe what
is false in order that they all may be
judged. Who did not believe the truth,
but took pleasure in righteousness. So
why do they believe what is false?
Because that's what they want. Why are
they being deluded by Satan? Because
they don't want the truth. They don't
want to turn to righteousness. They want
to continue in their lifestyle and want
someone to solidify them in that
lifestyle. Okay? But what's the key?
This man will be doing miracles, signs,
and wonders. But it's not from God. It's
from Satan. So right there, you're told
Satan has the power, demons have the
power to cause you to have dreams,
visions, and do miracles. In fact, even
Muhammad ironically said that bad dreams
are from Satan. And when you have a bad
dream from Satan, get up and spit to
your left three times.
Why? I don't know. But Muhammad said,
I'll show you the hadith. He says, when
you have a bad dream, that's from Satan.
So get up and spit to your left three
times.
What's the connection with spitting
three times after having a bad dreams
from Satan? Only Allah and his messenger
know. And guys, I'll give you the
receipts. So, right there, God told you,
be prepared
that even Satan can do miracles and
cause dreams and visions. Now, let's go
more specifically. Why would Satan want
to do that? Well, here's why,
right?
That's why I only bring dreams, visions,
miracles that are happening today where
Jesus is confirming the scriptures to
show Jesus is alive and the God of
scripture, the Jesus of scripture, who's
the real Jesus, is doing dreams and
visions and miracles to this day. But
I'm not that dumb to put my entire faith
on that because I also know Satan will
do
signs [clears throat] and wonders. So
what's the authority for me? The Bible.
Once I'm convinced the Bible is true,
then I use the Bible correctly
interpreted by the very church that God
entrusted the preservation of scripture,
which is why you're looking into the
Orthodox church because they all go back
time of the apostles. And I use that to
know whether this is of Satan or this is
your overactive imagination because you
had too much sausage pizza at night. But
here, the Bible already warned you.
Angels themselves will appear
to convince you to believe a another
gospel.
Obviously, these are evil angels, fallen
angels, but they're not going to appear
as such here. Galatians 18:9.
But if you even if we or an angel from
heaven, see, if we or an even angel from
heaven should proclaim to you a gospel
contrary to the gospel we have
proclaimed to you, let him be accursed
ana condemned. As we have said before,
so I say again now, if any man is
proclaiming to you a gospel contrary to
what you receive, let him be a cursed.
Now, one of the ways Satan will deceive
you is by sending
false teachers to preach a false Jesus.
preach a false gospel and introduce you
to a false spirit
and at times they will do it with
miracles because right here 2
Corinthians 11:4 watch here.
Watch here. I wish that you would bear
with me and a little foolishness, but
indeed you are bearing with me. Put up
with me as I have to now stoop to your
level and put you in your place because
they're getting very puffed up and
arrogant. So Paul had to now stoop to
their level to humble them and rebuke
them to bring them to their senses to
repent. For I am jealous for you with a
godly jealousy for I betrothed you to
one husband so that I might present you
as a pure virgin to Christ. Now the
language he had converted the
Corinthians to the faith as such he was
their spiritual father. So he's saying
you are like my
daughter.
You are the fruit of my ministry. I
converted you. So I'm now your spiritual
father. You're my spiritual daughter.
But when I converted you, I converted
you to give you to one husband because
the church is Christ's bride. Spiritual
bride, spiritual husband. There's
nothing physical or sexual. But I want
you to stay a virgin when he comes.
Well, we know about physical virginity.
What about spiritual virginity? How does
someone lose their spiritual virginity?
Here, this is how. But I fear that as
the serpent deceived Eve by his
craftiness, your minds will be corrupted
from the simplicity and purity of
devotion of Christ. That's how Satan
will rob you of your spiritual
virginity. By corrupting your mind, your
understanding, your thoughts about
Christ. For if one comes and preaches
another Jesus like Muhammad whom we did
not preach, or you receive a different
spirit which you did not receive, like
the spirit that visited Muhammad that
tortured and tormented him to the point
that Muhammad thought he was demonp
possessed and want to commit
experience no true prophet of God ever
underwent.
Okay? Or if they preach a different
gospel which you did not accept, you
bear this beautifully. In other words,
this is how Satan will seduce you to
lose your spiritual virginity. You will
tolerate
false teachers masquerading as servants
of Christ who preach a false Jesus from
the one you receive from us
and introduce you to a different gospel
and try to get you ins snared by a
different spirit which is an unclean
spirit. Now, here's the key with dreams.
Why am I mentioning this? Here's the
key. 2 Corinthians 11:13-1 15. Here is
the key.
For such men are false apostles like
Muhammad who claimed to be an apostle of
God, deceitful workers. They will do
deeds that seem righteous to deceive you
and to trusting them, disguising
themselves as apostles of Christ. And no
wonder for even Satan disguises himself
as an angel of light. Right here, you're
told, buddy, in the Bible, one of
Satan's MMO is to appear as a righteous
being, luminescent being, an angel, and
speak as if he's guiding you to the
truth. And he may even encourage moral
goodness.
Let me ask you a question before I
finish this. If I give you a bowl of
straight up poison, you know it's
poison, would you be dumb enough to take
it?
>> No. What if I give you a bowl
of Snickers or Reese's peanut butter
cups? You would be more prone to take
that, right?
>> Most likely.
>> Sad thing is
underneath the chocolate is the same
poison that's now been covered by the
chocolate in order to deceive you from
realizing that I made these with poison
and covered up. So now you take what
looks good and seems harmless, swallow
it and with it the chocolate cover up
the poison now kills you dead. So what
is Paul saying? Satan knows men are
righteous because they're created image
of God though sin has tainted that image
has erased it. So you have a desire to
worship. That's why everyone is in a
state of worship. Everyone worships
something or someone and your conscience
convicts you when you do wrong. Satan
realizes that for most people they are
religious. Even those who end up
atheist, they end up worshiping their
own intellect. Everyone is in a state of
worship. You're worshiping something.
Yet saint realizes it's very hard for me
to make them straight up Luciferians
worshiping me. And it's just as hard as
to make everyone an atheist because
their very innate
instinct, their nature because they're
created image of God is to want to
worship and their conscience convicts
them when they do something wrong or
their conscience will praise them when
they do something right because that's
what the Bible says the laws are in your
heart. I can't face that. That's what
he's saying. So what I'm going to do is
I'm going to give them religion. I'm
going to give them
a religion other than the true religion
in order to satisfy them in this
religious lifestyle. So they never think
about the truth because they think they
have it. So I'm going to appear as an
angel light and raise up people to them
preach my false gospel, my false
religious system and then masqueraded as
righteous and pious and as coming from
the true God. Therefore, it is not
surprising if his ministers also
disguise themselves as ministers as
righteousness whose end will be
according to their deeds. What's the
point? I'm not surprised you had a
dream, two dreams in which you saw
Arabic and the moon, which is a sign of
Islam. But then you have to wonder why
two guinea pigs. They're unclean
animals. Well, say, well, even unclean
animals stay in worship. All right? or a
man that you said was wearing a white
robe
with a rod, a staff, and he said you
couldn't see the face. Why?
>> Oh, because it was covered by light.
>> Say it again.
>> It was covered by light.
>> And what does Satan cover himself with?
>> Light.
>> You didn't see the real Jesus. You saw
Satan.
>> Yeah.
>> Now, someone will ask, "Well, how do I
know?" Because if you've been following
us, the Quran itself confirms the Bible.
And yet by confirmed Bible proves that
Muhammad is an antichrist.
[clears throat]
The Bible itself,
Jesus's ministry and the preaching of
the apostles were all fulfillment
fulfillment
of that which came before. Let me
explain what I mean. The number one
thing the Bible emphasizes is
consistency. If you remember Deuteronomy
13, how do you know a false prophet has
arisen? Because he's not consistent in
exhorting you to follow that which is
already established. Meaning, if God has
now given you signs and wonders, this is
my revelation that's established. Anyone
who comes after that must be in
conformity with in agreement with that
with that which is already established.
That's why God says if he then tells you
follow other gods you have not known,
God is testing you. Are you going to be
duped and then fall away from the
commandments that God has given you
which you know are from him or you going
to see it for what it is satanic
deception. So how do we know Muhammad is
an antichrist? Because he agrees that
the scriptures that came before him
possession Jews and Christians they are
the true writings. they are from God and
he supposedly comes to confirm them as
proof that he's a prophet.
But then his revelation contradicts it.
So he's agreeing with this principle.
You must be in the line of the prophets
in conformity with their message of
prophets already established and known
and believed in. And you cannot
contradict their message because if you
do then that means you're a false
prophet.